[Music]
i've been dreaming about this in my life
magellan's gold it's the biggest
treasure that's never been found five
billion easy
so when do we start yeah put that in
your head
hello hello i can hear him sitting right
next to you
your brother believed that there was a
final piece
well you know my brother's there what
else aren't you telling me
you have no idea who you partnered with
it's gonna take a little longer than i
thought kids
i assume we're 50 50 right
50 50 you get 10 that's me being
generous wow
let's play some parachutes what
500 years ago my family found the
vulture
and was betrayed
so much blood
you're doing great
this ain't over
hey you still with me
barely
what's with the cat she's just real what
the life seems super sad i'm not gonna
keep this thing exclusively in movie
theaters
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
what threatened us with catastrophe
turned out to be our salvation
the new history of mankind begins here
in these very minutes
[Music]
[Music]
and the earth was cycles and empty
and the darkness
over the abyss
[Applause]
every night i dream about that strange
city like his calling
the target is a writer his book is
titled godslayer and the writer's name
is kong
my boss is convinced that what happens
in the story is somehow affecting his
health you only have three days you
don't want to let us down
he's no mortal like
you're the one writing it so you can
decide what happens next
once
i've come to kill you
show yourself
you're going up against powers beyond
your comprehension you don't even stand
a chance
the story's not done
i have to finish it
one day you wake up and realize you're
not sure who the good guys are anymore
you're a federal agent involved in a
secret fbi program off the books what
kind of bad stuff do you do breaking and
entering
physical coercion
you name it i've probably done it
murder not on my menu
grandpa
gabe i've been thinking maybe it's time
i hang it up no
travis i don't know
i know i wasn't a great father but i'd
like to be the best grandfather i can be
natalie doesn't need a fixer like you
i've been writing about the story for
over a year
the united states government is killing
innocent civilians under the guise of
protecting democracy
under whose orders the director of the
fbi
how many would have to die for you to
stop looking the other way
[Music]
you need to complain gabe
you're confused about our relationship
you are my weapon you work for me
count me out you show me a little
gratitude if you want a normal life
my hand is now
where's my family
if i find out you had anything to do
with my granddaughter disappearing
you're gonna need more men
you'll be finished before the day is
over
everything i did
for you
are you really gonna shoot me travis yes
i will
grandpa
are you a good guy
i wanna be
darby 11 days
honestly what are we doing here i told
myself the same thing
rehab doesn't work but excuse me darby
phone for you
my mom is in the hospital i have to
leave darvey you know the rules
you leave and you're back in jail
[Applause]
the road's closed i have to get to salt
lake city no one's getting through until
the storm passes i opened up the visitor
center for some folks wait it out there
so what's your name darby sandy hey i'm
ash
ours do you have the wi-fi
no there's no wi-fi i got one bar by the
tree for about 10 seconds
i'm gonna get you out of here
[Music]
hey are you okay
make yourself comfortable
what we are here till the storm clears
[Music]
getting you out of here as soon as i can
the trick is
play the man not the hand
everybody's got tail huh
what's yours
you're gonna have to figure that one out
for yourself
go go go
put your weapon down
i don't want to die here
i have to go now
oh it's gonna be a long night
[Music]
the lights
[Applause]
[Music]
please
[Music]
i see a villain on his way
what are you doing
come on
[Music]
what happened to yang i don't know he
shut down last night he won't restart
does this happen before no
[Music]
if we can't get young fixed
[Music]
i'm not gonna buy another sibling for
mika
[Music]
it is an interior core problem
i need your permission to break open the
core
we've always known that some bots are
equipped with spyware
you might not want this part in your
house anymore
[Music]
i wish i had a real memory
what do you mean
[Music]
did you i want to be human
that's such a human thing to ask isn't
it
[Music]
may i be honest with you wait
it's not being honest an option for you
[Music]
do you want him back of course i do
i want him back too
i just need a little more time
[Music]
what are you watching
come on
[Music]
we all understand betrayal some of us it
was a system maybe it was our families
could have been a stranger
nothing i love more than watching grown
men squeal
[Music]
we are men we founded this country on
our backs now they want us to give up
power willingly into the hands of people
who are incapable of wielding it
over my dead
body
[Music]
what are we doing kind of like a pain at
the streets program
look i don't smack you in the mouth i'd
like to see you trying
there's some feminists who want to
attack my event
i need additional protection
she's gonna be in a body bag before
sundown
no one's gonna give it to us so we have
to take it
you know her but you clearly don't know
me
the violence you know it's gonna come
back to you it always does
you guys are professional murderers
you're coming for your blood remember
boys be nice
[Music]
i love being single i'm really looking
forward to it all the apps getting on
the apps yeah that's going to be cool
swipe left swipe right who's ugly
noah he was the love of my life
damn it
that is the love of mine
they're like fully in new relationships
she's leaving me for a middle school
drama teacher can't take it with this
guy look at that bio artist
director
human oh you're a human man i bet he's a
chill hang on
we can't give up we have to get them
back i really think we can break them up
in like no time it's on
baby give me one more time you could
become noah's friend i'm extremely
affable make him realize that i am the
one that got away i could seduce logan
i'm wondering how you would feel about
me joining you in your bed yeah
wow this is like cruel intentions only
sexier
how is it sexier it's not
okay get in there and turn his eye
are you ready to give all this up you
know popping bottles with the boys
grinding with the honeys you remind me
of that little singing uh cartoon gerbil
alvin the chipmunk yes okay yes
like a dermatologist's dream
[Music]
i've never done molly
is my heart gonna explode no no you're
thinking a crack bro that's what it was
can't believe we didn't think this part
all the way through we did not think
about that
[Applause]
it's
amazing so far
we are here for this nothing which is
exactly what we're gonna do the whole
time we're here wait a room above the
water is that safe
i hope i guess
oh my god
we could be anywhere what are we gonna
do
we need to focus on surviving
how long can we last in all this
they'll come for us
[Applause]
what was that what i just saw something
this is shark
[Music]
we're not gonna die
we're gonna be okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
tv
[Music]
[Music]
another
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
is
foreign
[Music]
based on quantum physics
particles are continuously created their
only destiny is to meet and disappear
into each other the same thing happens
when two people fall in love
i really needed you last night i was
busy training i'm always busy and i
still find time for you
how'd it go today
we're not there yet yeah i know keep
this up you're not gonna make the team
you only be living in that trailer can't
rest your life do you roy
do you know where steve is i don't know
where he went come on have some fun
[Applause]
[Music]
where are you taking
[Music]
do you me in love yes i do i just don't
want it
do you remember anything about that
night
i
don't remember
it wasn't your fault
she's convinced that she was with steve
that night and steve is telling the same
story
what was i wearing i can't remember them
what happened between the two of you
that night
turn around
[Music]
the bond between two particles
is only valid in the microscopic realm
you weren't with me why are you lying
it cannot be applied to the human world
because human beings
are much more complicated
[Music]
smell that air dudes well this weekend
just got a whole lot more interesting
yo maybe she's had enough maybe you
should shut your mouth hey slow down
cowboy
stop it
you got me
over here
scratches on your face your skin under
her fingernails we are not going down
for this what are you doing what does it
look like
it's kelly
the camera
[Music]
you hear me
is that you kelly
all we want is that camera
i've tried to be nice kelly
but now you're just pissing me off
when the [ __ ] hits the fan
don't forget i try to be nice
wakey wakey kelly
[Music]
ah
[Music]